on est tellement formaté au quotidien
pour atteindre des objectifs trouver le
partenaire idéal d'avoir un bel appart
et aller dans les meilleurs restaurants
et puis le monde s'écroule état
d'urgence renforcée dans tout le pays
des mesures d'endiguement tracés
et on se demande à quoi tout ça a servi
[Musique]
vous avez l'air crevé
ouais en effet alors c'est comment
ta
a réservé cette maison sur Airbnb
je pense pas qu'il était changeant de
sujet c'est comment là-bas c'est bien
enfin sauf que je suis passé
que tu dis
tu vas réussir à te faire un ami
il y a pas de la dernière fois que j'ai
mangé des pâtes
vous avez pas besoin de maquillage
est-ce que je veux d'un homme qui veut
pas être auprès de moi alors qu'on vit
le pandémie ce qui compte dans la vie
c'est d'essayer d'atteindre le bonheur
et les gens nous jugeront quoi qu'il
arrive et quoi qu'on fasse alors autant
faire ce qu'on veut et même dans la vie
tu aimes le karaoké
[Musique]
les uns les autres le monde devait
disparaître j'irai me cacher là vous
êtes qui j'ai l'impression
que nous
tu t'en vas mais toi tu restes
combien de temps vous croyez que ça va
durer mon travail me dit deux semaines